Salut, les Mentalos !
Dans la vidéo n°112 du MentalVlog,
je vous avais demandé ce que vous pensiez
du mentalisme, en terme de clichés,
qu'est-ce que ça vous amenait
comme images dans votre tête.
Vous m'aviez répondu des trucs parfois pertinents, rarement,
c'était plutôt souvent What The Fuck?
Alors aujourd'hui,
voici LA définition du mentalisme.
La version du dictionnaire, c'est :
"approche dont le but
est de cerner le fonctionnement de l'esprit humain,
en particulier la conscience,
notamment par l’utilisation de l'introspection."
La paternité du mot "mentalisme"
vient d'un philosophe anglais de la fin du 19e siècle
qui l'avait utilisé
pour l'opposer complètement au matérialisme,
c'est l'inverse.
Mais en même temps, on trouve le mot "mentalisme"
dans le domaine du spectacle, des arts du spectacle.
Jean-Eugène Robert-Houdin avait écrit dans un livre,
"Comment on devient sorcier" ,
plein d'expériences sur la prestidigitation de l'esprit,
on pourrait aussi appeler ça
la "magie mentale."
Au final, je vais vous faire une révélation,
le mentalisme c'est tout ça
et c'est rien du tout en même temps.
Parce qu'il y a pas de définition précise,
personne s'est positionné
pour dire "voilà ce qu'est le mentalisme"
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui,
chaque mentaliste à sa propre définition du mentalisme.
C'est un espèce de mot fourre-tout,
un sac fourre-tout,
on y met ce qu'on veut à l'intérieur.
Et c'est pour ça que vous allez trouver
des médiums qui disent être mentalistes,
des voyants qui disent être mentalistes,
des comportementaliste qui disent être mentalistes...
Mon boulanger dit qu'il est mentaliste.
Je taquine un peu, mais c'est vrai,
on peut tous se dire "je suis mentaliste,"
c'est très facile de s'autoproclamer mentaliste.
C'est un peu ce que j'ai fait d'ailleurs.
J'ai utilisé ce mot-là
pour mettre mes compétences derrière ce mot.
Dans ma bibliothèque, j'ai plein de livres
qui traitent du mentalisme d'une manière différente.
D'ailleurs, je vous ferai vraiment
une vidéo sur ma bibliothèque un jour.
Peut-être même deux vidéos
ou trois vidéos... J'en sais rien.
Mais je vais vous donner
ma définition du mentalisme.
Comment moi je pratique ça
et comment je visionne mon mentalisme.
Ça veut pas dire
qu'elle soit juste pour tout le monde,
ça veut juste dire que c'est la mienne
et que tout ce que vous voyez est en cohérence avec ça.
Alors, je considère le mentalisme
comme quelque chose issu de la prestidigitation.
Pourquoi ? Parce que la prestidigitation,
c'était déjà la connaissance de l'autre,
c'était déjà savoir détourner l'attention
psychologiquement d'une personne
et c'est fait pour bluffer les gens.
Tout ça, ça se rejoint.
Donc, y a une partie illusionnisme, on va dire,
dans mon mentalisme.
J'y mets aussi des principes de psychologie
puisque dans tous rapports qu'on a avec les autres,
on est obligé de s'intéresser à la psychologie
et moi, je m'y intéresse énormément.
Donc tout ce qui rentre
dans le domaine de la psychologie, je le mets dedans.
De fait, en lien avec la psychologie,
tout ce qui concerne l'influence,
je le mets dedans aussi, dans le mentalisme.
Ça veut dire aussi que je vais m'intéresser
à des choses très variées, comme l'hypnose
ou même comme des choses un peu borderline
comme la chiromancie,
c'est la lecture des lignes de la main,
la chiromancie.
- Chiroman-quoi ?
- Chiromancie !
Ça veut pas dire que je crois
dans la lecture des lignes de la main.
Ça veut dire que je trouvais intéressant
de savoir comment
on pouvait peut-être manipuler quelqu'un
ou voir l'effet Barnum agir réellement sur quelqu'un
ou peut-être me confronter à la constatation
que ça fonctionne.
C'est une approche en fait très pragmatique
d'un savoir qui a ses règles,
donc je m'y suis intéressé.
Mes domaines d'intérêt sont du coup très larges,
pour ma culture.
C'est pas forcément que je crois
en tout ce que j'étudie, mais j'étudie beaucoup.
Je mets aussi dans le mentalisme,
tout ce qui concerne la mémoire,
tout ce qui concerne la manipulation des maths
et la visualisation d'une manière générale.
Parce que tout ça est interconnecté.
Pour faire beaucoup plus simple,
pour moi le mentalisme,
c'est déjà de s'intéresser
à tout ce qu'on peut faire avec son esprit
et à comment fonctionne
l'esprit de quelqu'un d'autre.
Donc de fait, de s'intéresser aux autres.
Voilà donc ma propre définition
qui n'engage que moi, évidemment,
puisque je l'ai créée pour moi sur mesure
et ça vous aidera peut-être à comprendre
mon approche dans les vidéos ou en spectacle.
Demain, je vous fais une petite vidéo
sur le non-verbal qui, j'espère, va vous plaire.
Mais c'était pas celle qui était prévue.
J'ai besoin de vous,
j'ai une question à vous poser.
Au tout départ de la chaîne,
je faisais régulièrement des vlogs
et après j'en faisais un par semaine.
Et puis, là ça fait 15 jours que je dois sortir un vlog
sur le festival Face & Si
que j'avais fait avec les L.E.J.
J'arrive pas à le sortir
parce que je vois dans les stats
que le vlog, les vlogs d'une manière générale,
c'est ce que vous aimez le moins.
Alors je vais vous mettre un sondage
pour savoir si vous voulez
que je continue à faire des vlogs ou pas.
Prenez quelques secondes pour y répondre,
ça me permettra d'y voir plus clair
et de faire toujours du contenu
adapté à ce que vous voulez vous.
Si cette définition du mentalisme
vous a permis d'y voir plus clair,
faites-le moi savoir
en laissant un petit pouce en l'air !
Déroulez également le descriptif de la vidéo.
J'y mets plein de choses
et souvent dans les comms,
vous me posez des questions
dont la réponse est dans le descriptif.
Et puis bien sûr, abonnez-vous
puisque le MentalVlog,
c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
du 1er janvier au 31 décembre.
Donc rendez-vous demain à 17 h.
Ciao !
Je joue mon spectacle en entier
le 23 septembre à la Garenne-Colombes,
c'est la date la plus proche de Paris
si jamais vous voulez venir.
Sinon y a toutes les dates de tournées
sur mon site.